Okay. I hope you're beginning to find some of
these relationships pretty intuitive. Let's start over here with
the close ones. You would be 50% related to
your sister and 50% related to your mother. Remember we
just got done talking a few exercises ago about
how that 50% is not the same kind of 50%.
You're also 25% related to your grandparents and your
aunts and uncles. Of course this is because an individual
parent is half related to which of their
parents. So if you're 50% related to your parent,
half of that would be 25%. Now you're
12.5% related to each of your great-grandparents. As well
as your granduncles. The siblings of your grandparents.
So I don't know if you're noticing a trend
here. We've got this set of 50%. Alright? And
then this set of 25%. And then this set
of 12.5%. And now we also need to
include first cousins in this. And then we move
one more out. We would have great-great-grandparents and
what not. And then we'd have our first cousin
once removed at 6.25%. And our second cousin
would be 3.125% roughly. Notice that at each extension
we've essentially cut it in half from 50%. Half
of that is 25%. Half of that is 12.5%.
Half of that is 6.25%. Half of that is
3.125%. Now, because of recombination during myosis. These numbers
are not exact. This is not exactly. We could
put a little about sign, a little tilde, in
front of each of these, to represent that you're
going to have a, on average. A 25%, 12.5%, so
forth and so on. About the only relationship that
you can guarantee you're going to be exactly 50%.
Is the father, and the mother. Everything else has recombination
playing a role. And because that doesn't happen the same way
every time. You can get a little more. A little
less. From one relative or another. This is just an approximation.